This cow has an illusion face.
See the people about to kiss?
And oh my gosh, what's this?
Nice.
It's episode 44 of IMG!
If you eat too many Pringles you'll feel like
this.
And if you look like this, your kids will
too.
Now, if you look at this right in the middle
and move your head towards and away, the stars
will appear to rotate.
And speaking of rings of things, these are
4 perfectly round circles.
Give yourself a new face in the sand or, if
you're lucky, find a sweeter face in some
ice cream.
Now if this one dot represents all the fire
power used by all sides during World War II,
one Poseidon submarine contains the raw explosive
fire power of 3 world wars.
Oh and the rest of these dots?
They represent the total fire power of all
man made nuclear weapons currently on Earth.
Vertical comic time.
Okay, alright, cool.
Zoom in.
Yep, that's what I thought.
Now, let's be serious.
Animated GIFs.
Of course, when the format was first created
its developers pronounced it "jif," which
is reflected in their parody phrase "Choosy
developers choose .g[j]if."
But the Oxford English Dictionary says that
both "gif" and "jif" are correct.
The music playing right now, by the way, was
designed by sound therapists.
It's called weightless and it was constructed
to biologically be the most relaxing noise
possible.
It causes your brain waves and your heart
rate to synchronise.
According to the researchers, the next most
relaxing songs ever made in order are these.
And now a company that makes custom-stuffed
animals based on your children's drawings.
Enjoy.
Ah, come on, cheer up.
Here's a cleaning cart with a big grin.
Which these girls don't have.
I mean, come on, he'd rather touch a koala
butt.
Let's get infographic-y.
This interactive site shows when Mosaic started,
what all of its versions looked like and moves
through Netscape to Opera, IE, and beyond.
And this flowchart lets you choose the perfect
book off of NPR's list of the top 100 sci-fi
and fantasy books.
Finally, here's a great infographic about
our solar system that shows distances from
the Sun to scale.
We've got the Earth, Saturn, all the way out
to dwarf planet Pluto and beyond.
Hey Vsauce! Michael Here!
That's right.
You just witnessed our first tweet ever.
You can find it @tweetsauce.
The first 1,000 people to follow us will be
the ones I truly love.
This will be a place where we put cool mind-blowing
stuff that doesn't make it to the videos.
So check it out...
And as always,
thanks for watching.